alright alright class is about to start
real quick now I don't want to go and
say that I'm the best dancer in the
world but they used to call me krump D
Dumpty aka tickle me elbow
[Music]
that's how ghetto people talk every time
they talk to they always got to take a
hand right over the fist real quick or
what they do ghetto people they like to
do this well they'd like to put hands on
the low she's alive I have all their
lotions you don't say my hands on my
lotions real quick it's been a dancer in
LA for about like 16 years you're saying
I'm real you know [ __ ] season the
[ __ ] you don't say real talk
I said I've been embarrassing people out
in the street cuz but I'm not saying I
don't get my [ __ ] due respect but I'm
getting my due respect what is going on
everybody we got a very special guest
with us once again you already know we
just got finished eating tacos and now
it's about time we learn how to dance
dance dance dance dance dance dance
dance can you say real quick how much
she is a deceiver and a bringer of
falsities earlier I was trying to put a
lob into our [ __ ] pants pockets but
let me show you something real quick
they don't exist it's fake just like
it's not even real pants dude what are
these hey you know what no because
you're gonna have a date later so the
guy who just don't just you know no
there's no days all right we're here for
a dance lesson okay the homeless dude so
if you guys don't know recently there
was a video that just blew the [ __ ] it
actually really blew up it I was
overwhelmed and I got all these covers I
mean was a really cool job with League
of Legends Riot Games and week they got
bunch artists like Madison beer and
chair of burns two girls from kpop she
idols and they created this ultimate
girl group and the song has been popping
off on
and Spotify there's a BTS video by the
way and it's me obviously the
choreographer and dancing in it and
that's over like to 8 million right now
it's crazy and all the comments are hey
there goes Davis Zoe's friend yep
not the [ __ ] choreographer or dancer
yep just David's those friends you don't
even need the first or last name dude
how long were you working on the project
three months but not yet but it was a
week long in Korea to create the whole
world's championship but it was so much
fun so I'm gonna have even more fun
watching this gonna do try to do this
okay you literally put a fake penis in
my [ __ ] mouth but you bleeped out the
f-word I don't know why that does
anything to my god [ __ ] well let's
see you do the dance first in person
without me in it because I got [ __ ]
12 we're only going on an 8 count if you
can [ __ ] get that far can even get
that far less how terrible the teacher
is you were to put them down before you
even started alright I'm too heavy
I'm sorry you you can do it alright
let's go again
6000 846 to scrub what you just broke
the laws of physics how the [ __ ] you did
that should do how does the song go
down down down down down down down
kimchi jjigae coke boy everybody so Joe
are you going to lift up the right push
it down this way so think of like your
hip going yep someone's like pulling
your hip that so you're going like this
yeehaw
okay
this is a [ __ ]
so you're coming in right yes okay to
pick one I want you right here okay
you're gonna throw your arms up from
you're gonna lift up your life like this
is a hard part
yeah you want to light up
yeah yeah you got it you got it and it
stuck this way every two goes up it
doesn't look like the way you do it
though that's amazing
don't be judging dancers it should be
this is actually hard when you try it
cuz I mean I'm not do it on YouTube
that leaves compass on dancers videos
where I'm like yeah the technique would
be better if it's this way absolutely
not you're actually technically if you
did your count this way then technically
be better you could clean it up I
believe in those comes all time well you
know technically bro clean it up a
little bit man that air for cousin kind
of week bro for right you got to wave it
this way five seven six when you turns
out you're gonna serve the plastic
Toboso Tomica and you're gonna bring the
crown
[Music]
well that's better
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and start doing it dance dance
oh all right guys that's another day in
a life huh huh shouts - Ellen Kim Ellen
what can they find you real quick you
can find me on Ellen kimchi three
easterly post but on this again hahaha
butter on Instagram this girl is mad
talented she has been working with a lot
of high-level artists who she's been
like Cory
if you be see some of these k-pop dudes
I like to suddenly know how to dance
guess why this lady right here way thank
you they're not as good as me and they
don't pick up as facet what the [ __ ] are
you laughing right now they don't pick
up they don't pick up as fast as I do
but when I do see them I always give no
words of encouragement I'm like hey man
eventually you'll get there
[Music]
all right here it does that's darling
okay I can't do half of things you do
with your body okay ready go just keep
these younger you keep you teach them
don't teach me today I already have a
tutorial on this for you which you
sweating for no reason doing I'll have
you know that body weight is horn
no no Davis so got it like that huh yeah
no I mean you're my favorite part of
this is the ending dude what sucker it's
not even that first of all it's five six
seven eight
oh okay I don't know why you don't start
with one that's how it starts
why no stupid you must a film no am i
right you are